today we're gonna talk about analog
versus digital on a really basic level
most specifically we're going to talk
about how computers interpret an
analogue sound and turned it into a
digital file an analogue sound wave
would look something like this this
would be like a perfect sine wave which
would not really ever be heard of nature
but that's beside the point
this analog sound wave the computer
takes that and measures at all these
different points measures those and
turns those into numbers based on this
point right here so we could go up and
say oh this is point two seven says
point one six and this is negative one
point two later the computer could take
those numbers and reinterpret them and
turn them into actual sound again we're
also going to discuss a little bit of
data compression how computers compress
data that is in a sound file and image
file or a video file now the benefit of
compression is that it's a smaller files
was easier to store it takes up less
space and it's easier to send to
somebody else one of the ways this is
done in sound is it would take it less
often the sampling would be every two or
every three another way is that it would
just go up to here and say okay this is
point two seven well we're just gonna
measure everything from here so it's
negative three negative two negative one
from there if everything was around that
same area in images this is done by
taking the little tiniest possible
pixels and just measuring it in groups
of sixteen and finding kind of the
average color of that the most important
thing to take away from this video is
you're gonna want to use digital files
they're gonna have a better quality and
when you're looking at compression you
really need to look at how far you're
willing to go to ensure that the user
still has the best experience